va jouer à tout prix en gros mourir
parce que je me disais la douleur que
j'y vais tous les jours ne pouvait pas
être pire que l'oeuf que n'importe
qu'elle suscite
[Musique]
ça a commencé par des brimades des
insultes ce mon poisson famille ce que
l'on famille d'estaing donc c'est un
être lui d'être gros tous les petits
insultes comme ça puis ensuite ça
commence et les coûts les coûts en
récréation par exemple et moi j'étais
plutôt du genre timide je rêvais tueur
dans mon coin je passais les yeux
quelques cas manquer dans mes yeux je
faisais tout pour attirer l'attention
sur moi précités à une seule personne
puis deux puis trois et au final ça peut
être toute la classe qui commençait à me
jeter des chiots dans la tête des
écoutes compagnon daudet et voilà des
insultes et la plupart du temps à chaque
fois c'est moi qui prenais part le
professeur c'est moi qui me faisais une
mode au terme de son carnet parce que
moi je me tourne dos pour voir qui est
ce que c'était qu'il avait dans un stylo
et finale c'était même pas de danse moi
qui étais punir
[Musique]
ils m'ont mis un revolver sur la tempe
demandé la somme de 100 euros et monde
ici de match verra même pas honte tu
rentres à la fois ta famille on sait où
tu habites
[Musique]
je suis parti avec un sac à dos en
éclats brûlé dedans un briquet et sans
rien avec et je suis j'étais le long du
canal
il ya un petit terrain vague où il ya de
l'herbe des arbres oui à un fleuve et la
personne âgée j'ai pris la bouteille
d'alcool à brûler gelé je me suis
aspergé par le torse sur le torse parce
qu'envoyer je pensais que mon coeur
allait brûler et que je serait décédé de
suite j'ai animé avec un briquet et là
j'ai vu les flammes qui commençaient à
monter il après deux mètres de haut me
suis relevé j'ai marché une bonne
centaine de mètres avec les flammes sur
moi et là j'ai plongé dans ma gueule
le fleuve près de chez moi
et
il faut absolument pas ramer en fait
parce que c'est ça qui servent un enfant
une personne victime de refoulement
c'est ça qu'ils savent c'est à quelqu'un
qu'on a confiance
peu importe un ami un proche un
professeur ou alain fabien du collège
peu importe il faut savoir que qu'on est
passé le camp c'est harceler
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je passe pas encore dans les
écoles c'est ma mère qui de l'oeuf et
parce que moi je me sens pas encore
assez capable de parler à des
adolescents mais je vois ma mère a parlé
dans les écoles ça sauve sa sauce des
vies en fait parce que je pense au plus
on va en parler au mieux ce sera au
mieux ça va bouger les choses